hello and to welcome to this video
playing Mara
Donovan all on the islands right yes
okay we already had a zero laughs I made
it I'm so stupid I Castle you of course
I know I don't want this I don't like
this line yeah this is what happens
there for four points short of the goal
okay this is not yeah it's not lost for
black or anything I just don't like the
position I absolutely don't like it yeah
and this is so easy for white a plane
okay okay that at least looks kind of
playable I have got some good
development here at least let's jump in
okay that's not that terrible maybe okay
it's the hmm
it's just some way for me to still make
castling tougher not really
Queen a5 he can just interpose I came so
I think I won't try to trade this yeah
ookay for would be flashy more but
doesn't work it just hangs but isn't
that kind of okay you were just shoot
for rookie aid and grabbing deform that
doesn't feel like he played in the most
principled way
okay
hmm I wonder look a two to trade let's
do it
yeah they drew T to it it was kind of
passive but the remaining pieces are
also looking good for me
Bishop age six coming or maybe maybe so
should I play at five year
I'm sure I don't like the unprotected
state of my night and so and so on but
it still looks pretty okay it's not
threatening to enter the position
lucrative one I got if I have some they
cannot cover the porn okay now I can
actually take I wonder if I should do
that or not if five is interesting he
cannot take because of Queen d1 leading
to mate then this is a good move yes to
five or six to five OH six that's nice
that's close to the all-time high
definitely
I mean shake him quite sure what the
hotel is to five seventeen so close call
and it was almost one year ago to five
seventeen so I'm like one game one or
two games short okay so that was good
then have a look at the game I was
really a little bit hmm not amused that
are there as screwed up the water my
movers cancels him because I want to be
flexible after that so that c5 is not
played and somehow I played c5 don't ask
me why okay anyway this this is some
lion I mean it's not it's not terrible
for black but I don't not a huge fan of
it and he played this now I really don't
know and he played it very quickly so
probably it is some kind of line but
I guess this is probably wrong I don't
know this is what the engine gives and
okay I mean I cannot allow this so I
probably have to take and play something
like that but it was hot and super
dangerous I don't believe in this for
black but okay it's it's kind of its
kind of complicated at least yeah no
this is this isn't so bad
I mean it's it uses the the development
i'm castled already he's not and now I
have a clear color to play so this
wasn't this wasn't bad at all very good
position now I think this was okay I'm
trading off this but d4 and it gets to
be weak and now f5 yeah this is this
position is very uncomfortable the
engine wants to play Queen to f4
maybe intending to go here if I take now
and he has this C pawn maybe I don't
think I would have taken I probably
would have played a strengthening move
this is no good because he can take now
is a bit better I probably would have
played like aged six or something like
that something that helps me a little
bit and later tried to take yeah this
was this was very helpful now after you
five yeah white has no move actually I'm
just taking sorry taking with the pawn
next and this pawn roller is unstoppable
it's really really awful yeah this is
this is the relatively best move the
engine wants to take on d4 win the night
but this all
it's pretty strong or maybe this one
okay yeah but okay you can't play you
can play this okay it's slightly Airy
King but those pawns are too strong okay
nice one thanks for watching